I'm Brooks Wheelan this is Nick Turner
this is Carl Hess
welcome to episode you say welcome like
it's a podcast
Jeffie music so funny
[Laughter]
[Music]
drove out to Santa Barbara we're gonna
make some lunch camp that we're going to
a swimming hole oh yeah that you and I
came to I've got poison I we did get
poison ivy we just came from the grocery
store we bought enough food to eat for
like a month the guy at Trader Joe's
laugh at the amount of booze we were
pricing we liked him he goes to Knights
you guys are like yep I was like now
he's said no shame
I was ashamed with how much booze we but
I was thinking saying nothing cuz I
don't talk to cashews
this is actually a good spectrum though
cuz Nick hates camping I love camping so
you know we're operating on both sides
of the spectrum I really do hate camping
and except he's not gonna swim of course
I'm not swimming they're raising more
than anything in this world I'm not
going to be filmed with my shirt are you
can swim with the shirt there's no shame
I've left multiple auditions and they
asked fatty to pull his did you pop that
off I'm out I'm really excited this
Cameron guys start duty at the Golden
State
they say put up your tent first that's
no use amateur-hour [ __ ] buzz before you
need a proper tent buzz okay how does
this work one pool to turn oh whoa
this is cool as out there's no way the
beer and there is that's like a goddamn
hoe you pull this up to release the
pressure on the top I don't know maybe
Wow turn it says thanks deadly oh yeah
see if this works any better we found
out there's no fires allowed which is
devastating oh that's so much nicer
there we go
Wow here we go it's gonna be gross it's
gonna be it's very war when when Brooks
was picking this out both Carl and I
said we weren't gonna drink tea I did
say that I think like I guess we should
get this candy this literal keg it's
over a gallon of beer and there's no way
to keep it cold no I mean how is it it's
all foam out of ten boom out of ten yeah
did you guys ever have the thing in
college we're like people if you had
foam they like whipped wipe the inside
of them yeah the gross as possible it's
effective Oh disgusting 100% effective
I do it every keg party I go play flip
car yeah hell yeah I feel like if we're
gonna finish this beer we need to start
playing slow good oh [ __ ]
I can actually show you the table I'll
show you this table okay this is for
real he has a custom flip Cup table
that's why there was no room in the car
what is that it's the most 1960s thing
you've ever seen it's this is gonna blow
your mind oh my god so many places to
get your fingers caught in it Oh
nothing's rad no it's amazing it's a
picnic table yeah dude
holy [ __ ] this thing is garbage juice
table
that's that's it's dangerous boom I
don't feel safe
no I it feels like it could snap at any
moment how cool this is a great table
for like a kid's table during
Thanksgiving
yeah hundred sit over there on the
folding one I feel like it you if you're
cutting a steak you could easily just
cut right through the table right
through this is yeah don't touch that
okay well what is it one batter we have
it one do one flip Cup game real quick
before we get started on this yeah I
mean it's gonna the edge is kind of be
hard but let's let's try I haven't
played flip Cup in like three or four
years we're gonna use the we're gonna
use the beer from a verse diner
basically a punishment imagine if we had
worse beer to use I'm not perfect let's
play flip cup the alternate title and
all your friends who enable you yeah
this like they're like hey do you have
other like let's get a wider net of
people I'm like these are the only
people whose Confederation of
degenerates that I can offer you yes
pretty much
he's like six people who will hang out
with me overnight and that's it okay
with Cheers that we dream you got to
show you how much foam is in this real
quick it's pretty fun it's all foam like
it's disgusting but it works oh my god
sick drastic times call for drastic
measures
you know I got one of the dirtiest faces
in Hollywood who's that dirty face
[ __ ] get him in here Turner
you're goddamn right Trey Turner Cheers
let's go go oh that's gross [ __ ] you I
don't think that counts no and he gets a
minus 1 minute because he spit
[Music]
at least it wasn't throw up on good god
we put it in ice for like literally five
minutes that was terrible
alright well another great memory made
on that table I haven't unpacked this
since the last travels in such episode
so it's filthy and who knows if I even
grabbed everything I'm gonna go I like
underneath the tree yeah me too and if
we're not gonna have a fire I could just
put mine right here what are you doing
over there don't you want to stay close
to me I mean you don't want to talk well
the tape the tape the tables there Who
am I gonna gossip with that night Nick
Nick I'm gonna be in the car man you're
enough they're definitely gonna be in
the car slept in a car before it is
terrible
yes I assume that would be terrible
you're gonna wake up for this channel
worse than sleeping on the ground with
no tips
um Ruben I brought this for both of us
no I'm too too proud I'm too much of a
snorer you would hate me oh you're a
snorer he is my god you get in that
[ __ ] in the car I'd love to get in
but you gotta get your [ __ ] out first I
forgot about your snoring well you're
not gonna forget again boom see how
quick done Majan if we were both in
there we both can fit in that is it's
like a full-sized bed have you ever
slept in a tent before I was a child
before I had my own house I forgot that
we were gonna go camping with The Critic
it stinks I have a king-size bed and see
how much Nick hates can he like
legitimately hate so there's a beautiful
she's naked
come here I don't know you need to do
some self-reflection
this is what you do yeah that's why I
got smaller what are you doing monkey
what the hell
hey Brooks boom oh my god here god that
was like an orangutan we have a knife
you make slices
no what do we have forks there goes my
Chet and you want me to sleep in there
goes this was not a tsunami the latest
breeze if your tent is in the bathroom
that's right sleeping now baby no go
indie Alice
[ __ ] it goes there's no way you've done
this before
see that's pretty good it does look
pretty comfortable it is for one a
little more fractured unit this time in
the first episode a wine drinker beer
drinker
vodka soda drinker all coming together
for the love of nature and content yep
and you promise this is going on the
Internet very good got my pillow don't
don't know why I only brought one I
should've brought maybe 15 Adam could
have brought them but you can make up
for lack of blankets
[Laughter]
I might actually sleep with you Nick try
it out with this okay all right I feel
like when the door is closed your legs
are like your legs are not gonna be able
to our legs are like out of the car
doors open the doors can be opened early
Ving the door Oh should we all three
sleep in here yeah sure alright so
sleeping arrangement success good for
now we could lose that segment probably
Carl Stu's food so he's he's in charge
of cooking
got some nice burgers for lunch and then
off assuming all these burgers are great
oh definitely his shot of these birds
think those are done looking pretty done
oh come on we're roughing it I'm
sleeping in a [ __ ] car in a car here
let me slice my video with a spat
where's that picado burgers burgers
friendships this is really good this is
actually really good well Thank You Carl
I would say lunch success maybe if
someone had literally even once told me
about it before we got here I'm a bit
prepared but this long-standing
tradition for Michelle no one's ever
seen was lost on me but let's do it one
more time ok right ok you Carl lunch
we're gonna lose that eventually this up
friends I'm out ok but we got anything
you gotta go full extension do full
extension Carl you work up to it I'm
warming up show you how it's done we're
talking full extension I don't own it
but I instantly became a master of it so
you had a full extension I don't see it
happening I don't see a full kitchen oh
ok I'm ok with you nuts women full
extension full extension Brooks there we
go he did it alright Carl you gonna join
the club all over [ __ ] Rick over
Razor Ramon he's got a white shirt on
don't try to look cool when you do it
Wow full extension
full extension Oh congratulations
well Wow we're incredible people we're
gonna check out the swimming hole which
Carl have been to it's fantastic and
we'll see if the levels I already don't
like it ok we're getting
in that hole you're getting that damn
hole come on
oh he takes one foot I know where the
alleys going gets back in the car goes
to sleep
don't be dig around my house okay check
out how big this chair this pinecone
holy cow yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
solo holy [ __ ]
yeah it's like six feet lower this is
really bad the water was up to the lake
here last night how long has it been
since you came two months hey Joe once I
don't know if you can see we climbed up
to that middle of rung yeah we were
jumping off there
yeah but we're side in the dashboard I'm
just doing what they tell me they want
footage
it was 20 feet away from them even get
high over here
[Applause]
[Music]
your shirt and we are [ __ ] armchair
quarterback I'm sure that's a [ __ ]
you like [ __ ] killing it as any
Richter on this episode hello and
welcome to the sidekick show I'm your
host Nick Turner the next two days while
I'm the sidekick aren't Brooks's show
I'm gonna be hosting my own show on the
side Brooks doesn't know about it so
don't tell him it's just an idea of me
and Bill cooked up but if it's just
funnier and I don't think there's any
way it can't be Brooks's show will never
air just vote no vote no call through
this is exclusive content for the
sidekick show if I see this end up on
your show I'm gonna kill you evel
knievel you got nothing on me 50 60 feet
here we go ah oh my god I cut out for
like 60 of the feet but I did it for
real
that's Carlyle 60 feet up crazy this is
pre mellow night you know see you next
you did great man yo I've never been so
proud of you guys
it's incredible watching you guys do all
this work honestly I want to change mine
to success yeah we're back on the
sidekick shop Brooks's idea was a dud so
we're gonna do something I cooked up
we're gonna walk around here drink
another bottle of wine
it'll be our 18th I'll see you on the
other side I've been keeping track at
home we got a cave big news fennec oh my
god doesn't get more cave than that
folks oh that's scary it's terrifying
you gotta get in there climb in yeah
you're the ho see how far back it goes
all right this ain't the sidekick show
anymore you think there's some critters
in there there's definitely bears here
right it's California it's now there's a
bear on the flag don't tell me there's
not bears oh my gosh oh wow shut up no
I'm not joking or anything like a
full-on cat we're a freakin cave I give
you slept in here you'd be so
comfortable you can Sapir tonight Nick
we're here at the midnight society Nick
Turner we discovered a cave and we
crawled in like you shouldn't
I'm not we might be the first people in
this cave yeah for sure
no there's two beer bottles in here to
see if it was too scary
yeah pretty far I'm actually really
happy that we're in the cave it's
exciting I feel like a Thai soccer
player yeah okay
three cave secrets one from each of us
think you've never told anyone that you
never want anyone to know and it'll
never be told to anybody else okay one
time I came on my shirt and I guess they
cleaned up with my shirt
the black shirt and I clearly had come
on my scooter as a my friend came and I
said no it's ice cream
I think I'll add roommate and one day
one night I'm a 19 year old boy started
jerking her and he goes you jerking off
I said no he said I can hear there was
this a sock up here
what was my explanation and yeah it's
for the noise I don't know like we were
just both in a tent and I was like I
really wish I could jerk off and he was
like let's just like turn our backs
together in Jericho exactly we were just
like both horny I was like well just
like look over there I like a look over
here it was like dark there's a ton
mosquitos all right here we can't go
outside we're gonna cut all this oh my
god critter get me out of here critter
the [ __ ] out here it's a rodent it's
cool dude I'm done ah I'm not I don't
want to be in here I feel good about
what happened in there so I would say
cave show success
because it drink some more wine and over
there at the beach which was the initial
plan yeah unless we run into another
[ __ ] cave yeah
here's Chris
[Music]
let's go
holy [ __ ] look at that dude's tiny dick
oh he's like Trump according to stormy
Daniels I don't know who either of those
people wish I did it
do you guys know do you guys know about
Charlemagne like who are you talking to
that's very nice out here it's so nice
if it wasn't for Brooks you have to be
incredible oh I like this but we said
stop carving you got both shoes on buddy
I know these shoes are good for a boat
yeah let's you know boat shoes are you
can't wear sneakers on the boat do you
not know about you talk about this in
the cave but you know we need this
tennis ball if you find trash when you
camping it's you can't leave it oh I
thought you're gonna push me as and we
genuinely like pretty upset I think I
make your broken glass kidding oh now I
get to be the armchair QB that was my
wine stain I'm gonna miss it I called it
Harvey wine oh [ __ ] dude that was really
solid so overall I feel like swimming
home sick yes
we got to go like this it's gonna be a
second I'm scared no I'm paranoid about
that poison ivy holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
keep coming keep coming what is it
Rachel Rachel keep coming yeah what was
that Rachel stay over here Hey
oh the cameras roll the camera yeah
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] drinks right now
we got to really go with this you can't
go that way
scary dude it's real for real
Mountain Lion it's for thanks for real
aah
break some rocks throw some rocks throw
some rocks throw some rocks to that yet
pulled back from the swimming hole yeah
we sure are that's pretty fun
oh not staying there a guttural growl a
growl from the darkness it was like that
but scarier like a predator because Nick
looks really cute when he doesn't it was
it suck oh yeah yeah what do you mean
Carl
we got Brussels sprouts with a little
ghee and red onion I'm just whining
what's key key is clarified butter
what's clarified butter with butter that
has the milk solid strained out of it
what's that a thanks for clarifying
[Music]
[Laughter]
Carl can I have the clipper no you can't
let me flip them no they're not ready to
flip yet why are you flipping them I
told you not to what the [ __ ] you doing
man you drop that's your steak
that's [ __ ] your steak dude stop stop
look what you're doing just please
please
[Laughter]
that's my dad it's next day the first
thing Brooks said when he woke up he
goes do we make those steaks we got here
pulled up dick dick made a beautiful
wonderful bed for himself that was
really fine Carl took an hour you take
an hour to get your tip together my god
popped right up had delicious hamburgers
right sure you know straight over that
swimmin hole just in time for no Sun
yeah we really did we didn't end there
or water or water or water you're
lacking some key swimming hole things
but we met you know we made it work made
the best of it that's what camp is all
about adapting jumping off rocks getting
in a cave okay here's a question if we
had heard the mountain lion first and
then seen the cave would we have all
gone in yes you're a percent chance that
could very well been the mountain I saw
the only thing
my mind with his family right we came
back made some steaks
those are good i season them poorly sure
with this dirt yeah yeah there's lobbies
here her God and then you know just and
then we really go on once the cameras
went off we all relaxed yeah we were
relaxed are we immediately went to sleep
yeah definitely went to sleep did not
stay up for hours drinking
I like that poem you told you recited
exactly we have we had poetry reading
you did Joan Didion right exactly you
didn't even he doesn't even have the
book he just had a dimmer at right up
here you know early and sober bedtime
for all yeah it was great friendship
success success